>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> You're having a
program a great deal
of details about Natasha Trethewey.
And I'm not gonna repeat
them except to acknowledge
that of the highest awards
in our field including
for example the poet-- the Pulitzer
Prize that's what she received
for her last book, "Native Guard."
And we know her very much as a poet.
And while we hear a poetry today,
we're also gonna hear something new
from her as listeners, as
readers which is her prose.
Like Natasha Trethewey,
I'm a child of Mississippi,
and with considering how best to
introduce her work with this focus
on people in a place and
time, I naturally thought
of the writers of our state.
I thought that the
parallels between her work
and partners regarding the
land is a living character.
Wealthy on the courage
of the individual,
Margaret Alexander Walker and
Richard Wright on the testimony
and even the rage of the submerged
voices, but I found an equal linkage
with Robert Frost and their
mutual care for the poetic turn,
for the shape note of
knowledge revealed in the space
between two lines of
suspended revelation.
Robert Frost stated,
"Poetry is a way
of remembering what it would
impoverish us to forget."
And when I think about what
Natasha's achieved here beyond
Katrina, that's what I think of.
This is a stay against
that impoverishment.
It is a stay against
that forgetting.
She says one line from
a quite wonderful poem
that hopefully we might here.
She says, "Bring only
what you must carry."
And clearly she assigned
herself that hardest of task,
she decided to carry the story of a
region, and a tragedy to a region,
and honestly a neglected story
of the Mississippi Coast.
And this was a burden
she gave herself
and she carried it to the heart.
And it is my honor and privilege
to welcome Natasha Trethewey.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
It's such an honor to be here.
I'm delighted to get to read a
little bit of poetry and prose
to you since I am in the
poetry and prose tent.
This book is in many
ways a hybrid itself.
Because I am a poet, I couldn't
help sticking a little poetry
in between all the prose
that I was writing.
The book is an attempt
to remember my hometown
and the other hometowns along
the Mississippi Gulf Coast
that were devastated
during hurricane Katrina.
I began writing this
book because I used to go
around the country giving readings.
And before I would read
from my last book of poems,
I would ask people
what they remembered
when they heard the words
"hurricane Katrina."
Always they said, New Orleans,
almost never did anyone say
the Mississippi Gulf Coast.
The poem is dedicated-- the
book is actually dedicated
to my brother Joe.
It tries to trace the rise of
tourism and the gaming industry
on the Mississippi Gulf Coast,
the kind of development fermented
by the gaming industry,
and also the kind
of environmental destruction
that went along with it.
It's interwoven with the story
about my ancestors who arrived
on the Mississippi Gulf Coast
around the same time that the City
of Gulfport got its charter.
And it ends up being a story
about my brother and his life
and what happened to him in
the wake of the hurricane.
A story that I think becomes
emblematic for the kinds
of suffering that people
who are often invisible
on the coast have endured.
I'll begin with the
poem from the book
that also is the first
poem in my last book.
They're both the first
poems in both of these books
because the poem underwent a kind
of revision after the hurricane.
I had turned this poem in to
my editor in March of 2005.
It was a very figurative meditation
on the impossibility of going home
or those places we've left behind,
not because the places are gone
or forever changed,
but because we are.
By August 29th of '05
this poem became literal.
Theories of Time and Space.
You can get there from here,
though there's no going home.
Everywhere you go will be
somewhere you've never been.
Try this: head south
on Mississippi 49,
one-by-one mile markers ticking
off another minute of your life.
Follow this to its natural
conclusion-dead end at the coast,
the pier at Gulfport where riggings
of shrimp boats are loose stitches
in a sky threatening rain.
Cross over the man-made
beach, 26 miles of sand dumped
on a mangrove swamp -
buried terrain of the past.
Bring only what you must carry -
tome of memory its
random blank pages.
On the dock where you board
the boat for Ship Island,
someone will take your picture:
the photograph - who you were -
will be waiting when you return.
Somewhere in the post-Katrina
damage and disarray
of my grandmother's house, is
a photograph of my Joe and me,
our arms around each
other's shoulders.
We are at a long-gone nightclub
in Gulfport, the Terrace Lounge,
standing before the photographer's
airbrushed scrim - a border of dice
and playing cards around us.
Just above our heads the words "HIGH
ROLLERS", in cursive, embellished -
if I am remembering this
right - with tiny starbursts.
It is 1992, the year
the first casino arrived
on the Mississippi Gulf Coast,
and with it a new language meant
to invoke images of high-stakes
players in exclusive poker games,
luxurious suites on the
penthouse floor, valet parking,
and expensive cars lined up in
a glorious display of excess.
Scenes from a glamorous casino
someplace like Monte Carlo
or Las Vegas - nothing like the
gravel parking lot outside the club,
the empty lot beyond it, and
the small, run-down houses
on either side, each
with a chained-up dog
barking into the night.
Not far from the club,
beyond the spot
that held the old Gulfport
City Limits sign,
is the neighborhood
my ancestors settled
in when they arrived
on the Gulf Coast.
Roughly five miles north
of the beach and downtown,
the place called North Gulfport was
once the northernmost settlement
beyond the city.
One of two historically
African-American communities
that sprang up along the Mississippi
Gulf Coast after emancipation,
North Gulfport has
always been a place
where residents have had fewer
civic resources than those extended
to other outlying communities.
Isolated and unincorporated,
North Gulfport lacked a basic
infrastructure: flooding
and contaminated drinking
water were frequent problems.
Although finally incorporated in
1994 - not long after the arrival
of the first casino - many of North
Gulfport's streets still lack curbs,
sidewalks, and gutters.
Before the arrival of the
casinos brought tourists
down Highway 49 toward the beach,
there were few streetlights
and North Gulfport
was cast in darkness.
When I was growing up there,
North Gulfport was referred to as
"Little Vietnam" because of the
perception of crime and depravity
within its borders - as if its
denizens were simply a congregation
of the downtrodden.
Even now, it is a place that
outsiders assume to be dangerous
or insignificant - run-down and
low income, a stark contrast
to the glittering landscape
of the post-Katrina beachfront
with its bright lights and
neon bouncing off the casinos
onto the water.
Were North Gulfport not
along the main thoroughfare,
making it necessary to drive
through to get to the beach,
it might be easily forgotten.
Witness, here is North Gulfport -
its liquor stores and car washes,
trailers and shotgun shacks
propped at the road's edge;
its brick houses hunkered against
the weather, anchored to neat,
clipped yards; its streets named
for states and presidents -
each one a crossroads of memory,
marked with a white obelisk;
its phalanx of church houses
- a congregation of bunkers
and masonry brick, chorus of
marquees: God is not the author
of fear; without faith
we is victims;
sooner or later everybody
comes by here.
In the year leading up to
landfall, a few miles up highway 49
from the beach, my
brother was beginning work
on the shotgun houses.
The boost in tourism brought by the
casinos had created a greater need
for housing, North Gulfport had
finally been annexed and the strip
of Highway 49 that
run right through it,
was undergoing a great
deal of development.
>> Where there had been
darkness for so many years,
streetlights appeared guiding
travelers from the beach
to Interstate 10, pass the Walmart,
fast food restaurants, motels,
gas stations, and convenient
stores up to the new outlet mall.
My brother's property was
right in the middle of it.
Most of it at the crossroads
of old Highway 49
and Martin Luther King Boulevard.
For years, the shotgun houses Sonny
Dixon had built languish in a state
of disrepair, unpainted
sagging, many still occupied
by tenants who'd been there since
he was alive, the rest vacant
and sometimes sporadically
occupied by drug users.
The remaining tenants
had paid the rent now
up to 250 dollars a
month, steadily for years.
Ms. Mary in the duplex at the
corner of MLK and Arkansas,
Chapman's Fruit Stand, and
AD's Bail Bond business
at old Highway 49 and MLK.
Armed with tools and experience,
Joe began repairing each one,
putting in new floors and carpet,
new countertops and appliances,
brushing on a good coat of paint.
Ms. Mary nearly cried when
Joe fixed up her house.
Each day whenever he was
outside, someone would drive by,
stop and roll the window
down to look.
People kept coming by to say,
thank you, he told me, and "Man,
I appreciate what you're
doing for the community."
For many long time
residents, it must seemed
as if Sonny Dixon had returned
in the form of his young nephew.
By the start of the summer of 2005,
nearly all of the houses
were renovated and rented.
In a few months with the profit,
Joe could get them insured.
Katrina made landfall
on August 29th, 2005.
Out in the Gulf, Ship Island
was completely submerged.
The storm surged up to 27 feet.
Mississippi officials recorded
238 deaths, tens of thousands
of people were displaced.
Even though she was a
renter, Ms. Mary had lived
in her duplex for nearly 30 years.
She survived the storm in it, but
before long, she'd have to leave
as the severely damaged structure
began to fall down around her.
Hearing her story, I thought of
Bessie Smith's Backwater Blues,
when it thunders and lightnings
and the wind begins to blow,
there are thousands of people
ain't got no place to go.
The kind of repairs her house would
need, Joe couldn't afford to do.
He'd spent all his savings on
repairing them prior to the storm.
Before the second anniversary
of landfall,
the city would demolish the duplex
and my brother would be struggling
to pay the taxes on vacant land.
[ Pause ]
>> Watcher, after Katrina, 2005.
"At first, there was
nothing to do but watch.
For days, before the trucks
arrived, before the work of cleanup,
my brother sat on the
stoop and watched.
He watched the ambulances
speed by, the police cars,
watched for the looters who'd come
each day to siphon gas from the car,
take away the generator,
the air conditioner,
whatever there was to be had.
He watched his phone for a
signal, watched the sky for signs
of a storm, for rain,
so he could wash.
At the church, handing
out diapers and water,
he watched the people line up,
watched their faces
as they watched his.
And when at last there
was work, he got a job,
on the beach, as a watcher.
Behind safety goggles, he
watched the sand for bones,
searched for debris that clogged
the great machines, riding the prow
of the cleaners, or walking
ahead, he watched for carcasses,
chickens mostly, maybe
some cats or dogs.
No one said remains.
No one had to.
It was a kind of faith,
that watching.
My brother trained his eyes to bear
the sharp erasure of sand and glass,
prayed there'd be nothing
more to see."
After my initial journeys
back home following Katrina,
I stayed away for a long time,
tough my grandmother asked again
and again to make the trip.
"I know I can't live
there anymore," she'd say.
"I just wanna see it one more time."
For three years, I kept putting
her off, saying, "One day."
So that at 92, she
could at least hold
on to the hope of getting there.
I never considered the
consequences of this tactic,
how it might haunt me later.
When I started going back more
often, it was because I had to.
And by then, it was too late.
It occurs to me now that I
have been waiting foolishly
for the recovery to be complete.
I had wanted to show her the
place she'd spent her life
without the narrative of destruction
still inscribed on the landscape.
During the year or
so, after the storm,
everything that has been disrupted
seemed to be starting to settle,
the narrative of recovery
overwriting the devastation.
My grandmother had lost a lot
of weight during her ordeal.
But in the nursing home at
Atlanta, she started eating again.
My brother too, seemed to on
his way to remaking his life.
Even without his rental units,
he was earning a living.
There was a good deal of
work to be had on the coast,
government contractors were hiring
Cruz [phonetic] for the work
of cleanup, and Joe
was doing it all.
I remember too, that he called one
day, excited about the possibility
of a small business loan to rebuild
his rental units, though later,
he'd learn that he did not
qualify for assistance.
Like a lot of people in North
Gulfport, he wasn't eligible
for the kinds of programs
that it helped business
and wealthier citizens
get back on their feet.
And it wasn't long before
the initial cleanup was done,
though recovery was still a long
way off and still hasn't occurred
for some of the poor
citizens in the region.
Just more than a year after
landfall, the contractors pulled
out of Gulfport and other
devastated Mississippi Costal towns,
leaving behind much less
work for people struggling
to recover and rebuild their lives.
Even the retail store Joe worked
in part time before the storm
did not rebuild on the coast.
The owners relocated the business
farther north where they had family.
Not only were jobs
leaving the coast,
much low income housing
had disappeared too,
and wasn't being rebuilt in the
same numbers as before the storm,
thus rendering recovery a lot harder
to achieve for many of its citizens.
I can't help thinking too
that the photograph we made
in 1992 foreshadowed something else.
Driving through the old
neighborhood not long ago,
I remember that my brother and I
had waited in line to have it taken.
The line had stretched around the
dance floor, and we stood there
with everyone else that
night to pay the 5 dollars
to pose beneath those
words; high rollers.
It was as if we needed to get close
to that image of luck and money
in a place where so many
people had so little.
Perhaps, it's better
the photograph is lost.
I know the desire to see the
images of the past in light
of the present would be too strong,
and I'd be tempted to read into it
in our gestures, the way
we held onto each other,
what I would not see then,
the irony of those words,
how they mock so many of the
people who stood beneath them.
[ Pause ]
>> The first letter of my brother
writes me during his incarceration
arrives on August 13, 2008, a week
after we bury our grandmother.
It comes bearing his name
and his inmate number, R0470,
along with a warning stamped in red
that the letter is from an inmate,
and that the facility, the county
jail where he awaits sentencing,
is not responsible for content.
He is a stoic in the letter
as he was at the church,
the day of our grandmother's
memorial service.
I know things are hard right now.
It seems like everything
comes at one time.
And I relived that morning while
thinking of him trying to be strong
in his cell, perhaps, because so
much has happened in what seems
like a short amount of time.
I feel that I have gone
through it as if I were walking
through was set, an
artificial backdrop
onto which our lives have been
projected, along with a story
that is already in process
and beyond our control.
I think of it now as
not unlike the fake town
at the dude ranch I
visited when I was a child.
The buildings were
rundown, mostly facades,
and I was surprised the first time
I saw the actor stage a shootout.
My grandmother and I stood
watching, at once part of the scene
because we were there and
not, as though we had walked
into some bizarre turn of
our lives, and it was playing
out right there before us,
and we were unable to stop it.
The morning we buried
are grandmother,
the church was like that.
Still in disrepair, the sanctuary
unused, the church seemed abandoned.
On the ground level, windows on both
sides of the church were boarded up,
and a couple of the
high windows up top
that overlooked the balcony
were still blown out.
>> I could see birds
flying in and out of them.
The church marquee
hadn't been repaired,
and most of the glass
were-- glass was missing.
A few letters hung on,
and oh, on its side,
what looked to be a broken
F. Missing its smaller arm,
it resembled the gallows in
a child's game of hangman.
Only the small bunker
attached to the back
of the church was functional.
It was the place food was
served after services,
and it held Sunday school
classrooms and a nursery.
When I call to tell the
caretaker, Mr. Crouch,
that I was bringing my
grandmother's body back to Gulfport
to have her home going ceremony
in the church she belonged
to her whole life, he thanked me.
Since the storm, we've lost a
lot of our members, he said.
Mount Olive is still struggling
to raise the money for repairs
that the insurance
company didn't cover.
Most people have moved on
to places that are still
in the process of rebuilding.
Mr. Crouch, now in his early 80s,
had done this job most of his life.
I had arranged with him to
have the doors opened early
so Joe would be able to have
some time with our grandmother.
The Sheriff had granted
him permission to come,
but only to a private viewing,
and we had to schedule it two
hours before anyone was supposed
to arrive for the ceremony.
My husband, Brett, and I
arrived early, even before 8 AM,
when officers reschedule to
pick him up for transport.
We didn't find anyone
there when we arrived.
No police car.
So we decided to circle the
block around the building
in case they parked somewhere
else, turning the corner
of Jefferson right in front
of my grandmother's house
onto the access road that runs
parallel to Highway 49, we saw them.
They were near in the
intersection of 49 and MLK,
headed in the direction of the jail.
I could see my brother's head just
above the top of the back seat.
When I saw the car's
blinker come on, I panicked.
It seems funny to me now
that in moments like this,
it becomes so easy to
ignore the rules of traffic,
of law and order on the road.
I asked Brett to speed up, and
he did, flashing the headlights
and honking the horn as he pulled
up close behind the police car.
When they stopped, I got out
and hurried toward the driver.
Later my brother would tell me
that the two officers
have been skeptical,
that because of the
condition of the church,
they hadn't believed any kind
of services could be
taking place there.
As I stood in the middle
of the road,
afraid they were just going take
him back, I could see the officer
in the passenger side looking at
me, my black dress, and stockings,
and shoes, while the other one
chuckled, "We are just going
to get something to drink," he said.
"We'll bring him right back."
We've been told when our request
to have Joe there was approved,
that we were not allowed to have any
contact with him, and that we'd have
to stay back several
feet from where he was.
I didn't even look
at him in the car.
When the officers brought him
back and parked near the entrance
of the church's auxiliary
building, Brett and I stood off
to the side, away from the entrance.
A few people had begun
to arrive early,
and I had to tell them they'd
have to wait outside in the heat
until the private viewing
was over and Joe was gone.
When he emerged from the car, I
saw that his ankles were shackled
and his hands were
cuffed behind his back.
I hadn't seen him like that
before, and I stood there trying not
to register any emotion on
my face as I watched him walk
into the church, flanked
by the two officers.
In my memory, this happens in
slow motion, like a trite scene
from a movie, and I feel
like I noticed everything,
particularly the sound of his feet
shuffling in the leg restraints,
the birds flying out of the
sanctuary and settling in the tree
across the street,
the whoosh of the door
as Mr. Crouch opens
it to let them in.
When Joe was inside several
feet, Brett and I follow,
shutting the door behind us.
The flowers haven't yet arrived, and
the low ceilinged room seems sparse,
homely, except for the fuse
they've managed to salvage
and the folding chairs
where the choir will sit,
the room holds only an organ, a
small podium, and wooden chairs
for the pastor and deacons, and
the platform bearing the casket.
Before Mr. Crouch shuts the
door to the makeshift sanctuary,
I can see Joe standing before
the open casket, his head bowed.
When Joe comes out a short
while later, his eyes are red,
and I look at him a
good long moment trying
to make my face convey
everything I am not allowed to say.
Perhaps the officers
are moved by all this.
The grandson in restraints,
the run down shirts still
wearing the vestiges of Katrina,
the small congregation there
to say goodbye to a woman
who wanted nothing more
than to come back home.
During the home going ceremony, I
can't help thinking of what recovery
and rebuilding means in
this little room dressed
up to served as the sanctuary.
My grandmother had made the
draperies that hung in the church,
and she'd seen her own
daughter eulogize before them.
And yet, here she was, being
remembered in a room that served
as church cafeteria,
beneath low ceiling tiles,
warped in stains reminders
that Katrina isn't over.
As my niece PJ stood at the podium
to remember her great grandmother,
I realized just how much she'd
lost in this ordeal, and I imagined
that for the rest of her life she
remember this time as underscored
by the devastation of Katrina.
She could mark the passing
of her great grandmother,
the arrest of her father, the
turmoil of these years as aftermath.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
People carry with them the blue
prints of memory for a place.
It is not uncommon to hear
directions given in terms
of landmarks that are no longer
there, turn right at the corner
where the fruit stand used to be,
or across the street from the lot
where Ms. Mary used to live.
Some time ago, before the storm,
my grandmother and I were shopping
in Gulfport, and we met
a friend of her shopping
with her granddaughter too.
The woman introduced the
girl to us by her nickname,
then quickly added the
child's given name.
My grandmother, a proud woman,
not to be outdone, replied, "Well,
Tasha's name is really Nostalgia."
[ Laughter ]
>> Drawing the syllables out to
make the names seem more exotic.
I was embarrassed, and immediately
corrected her, not anticipating
that the guilt I'd feel later could
be worse than my initial chagrin.
Perhaps, she was trying to say,
Natalya, the formal version
in Russian to which
Natasha is the diminutive.
At both names, Latin
root, the idea of nativity
of the birthday of Christ.
They share a prefix with words
like natal, national and--
>> -- although it was very
poetic prose was that?
>> Yes. You know, it seems too
big, I think, in many ways.
Too big for the kind of extended
meditation that I wanted to do
about the nature of historical
memory, interwoven with the history
of the Mississippi Gulf Coast,
as well as my family history.
I had in mind Robert Penn
Warren's segregation,
the book that he published two
years after the ground decision,
which was very much a travel
narrative, where he journeys back
to the south to rethink
his own relationship
to the place he comes from.
It was a lovely model for me, a
very slender book, but it helped me
to figure out a way
to tell this story
that I didn't think I
could tell in poetry.
Yes?
>> I have two questions.
The first one was, would
you talk a little bit
about your experience
with Cave Canem?
And then the second one is,
who are your favorite poets?
>> Okay. Actually, my very first
book won the first Cave Canem poetry
prize, which is how
it got published,
something I'm deeply grateful
for because it allowed,
all of the sudden, an
audience, you know.
I thought I would never
get a book published.
So it was great that
Cave Canem came along
for black poets to
send their work to.
I am actually gonna
be there as faculty
for the first time next summer.
So it feels like I get to give
back, you know, to this place.
I forgot your other
quest-oh, my favorite poets.
You know, there are so many, and
you know, it's always changing.
But the easiest thing, that I can
say, at least about my last book is
that I found a great
kinship with Irish poets
because of their relationship
to homeland and histories.
So for example, the work of
Eavan Boland and Seamus Heaney,
particularly his book, North,
the engagement with history,
that sense of psychological exile.
Of course, the first book that
my father gave me that I carried
around as my literary bible when I
was first writing to write poems,
was Rita Dove's, Thomas and Beulah.
I added to that Yusef
Komunyakaa's Magic City.
So if you take Heaney's North,
Eavan Boland's In a Time of Violence
and The Lost Land, and Thomas
and Beulah and Magic City,
those are my literary ancestors,
at least most, immediately.
Yes?
>> Hi, Ms. Trethewey.
In your book, Native Guard, there
are quite a few poems and form,
as well as [inaudible] forms.
And I was wonder if
you could comment on--
well, your thoughts on how form can
still be relevant for poets today.
'Cause you hear a lot of people
still saying, "Oh, you know,
form is for 50 years ago.
You can't use that."
So--
>> Yes, yes.
I have been told that I am
old fashioned because of that.
I can't imagine that I could write
about some of the difficult things
that I try to write about
without the scaffolding of form.
For me, it's a way of imposing
a very necessary restraint.
I found that-- I know a lot
writers will say this-- that some--
they turned to form for the
most difficult material.
But form is, of course, memorable.
I mean, that's not to say that free
verse writers haven't invented their
own sort of memorable cadences
in poems that we love and recite.
But there is something about
the memorable nature of poems
and traditional forms, those
cadences, those rhymes,
and in Native Guard, because
I was trying to remember,
trying to re-inscribed things
that have been forgotten,
I realized that I needed that
scaffolding of form to try
to create something memorable.
Thanks. Yes?
>> Hey. I'm from Pascagoula
a long time ago--
>> Hey, yeah.
>> And I just wanted
to say thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> The same.
I am long time Gulfport native,
lived in New Orleans for awhile.
So thank you.
>> Thank you.
Yeah. It's nice to have the hometown
folks ya'll, because-- yeah.
You know, people-- I mean,
you guys know the story.
I mean, so much of the media
did turn to the travesty
of New Orleans with good reason.
But it's a different story.
And the people I talk to in
the Mississippi Gulf Coast--
want the nation to
remember the difference
between the manmade disaster of New
Orleans and the natural disaster
that hit the Gulf Coast and
those towns all along the coast,
ground zero, for Hurricane
Katrina's landfall devastation.
Well, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.
[ Silence ]